There's no denying that Swift's optional
types are both unusual and tricky.
But if you're going to become
confident using Swift,
it's essential that you understand
optionals inside and out.
And beyond practical use, optionals
are sure to be a common target among
interview questions for iOS developers.
So let's start at the very beginning.
Why does Swift need this data type
that no other languages have?
The need for
optional types arises because Swift
disallows nil values in all other types.
As always, in the instructor's notes
please find the playground file to
follow along with the lesson and
the exercises file for practice.